[Music]
Christian
e
[Music]
w
for
oh man I've been playing
for 26
years been on the
road about 18 of those
years yeah yeah I'll go out for a little
b i play for an artist nam
fergon I lived in nville for about years
up there
yeah that's where I really learned like
how to love and make
[Music]
records yeah yeah pretty
much yeah it's a lot of fun what about
you
[Music]
how old
are that
is do you play out like
but you do right
the spirit of God is not here
I don't know that it
is yeah
we'll give you details
oh thanks okay um we'll give you all the
details on leadership transitions
finances things like that um if you call
the table home please stay after the
service so you can experience that um
next we have a potluck next week uh one
week from tonight October 6th we're
going to have a potluck in the Family
Life Center the theme is family favorite
so please sign up for that um you can
there's a QR code that will be on the
screen um you can sign up to bring a
dish for next Sunday um next if you're
not registered to vote um we have a
table in the hallway where you can get
registered and we really encourage you
to do that I'm a teacher please um so I
did it last week it's really great
really helpful um so please get
registered um next um looking well the
candles blew out but they're supposed to
represent
uh the sign of the presence of Christ
Among
Us just imagine he's here he is okay
uh okay I don't know why they blew out
okay um so
now now we exit the kingdom of noise and
productivity and hurry and we enter into
the kingdom of silence and Stillness and
simplicity a Sacred Space a place for
for prayer worship and
adoration a place to behold Christ the
revelation of God heartbeat of creation
allow The unforced rhythms of Grace to
find you and to mend your heart may we
all come
home thanks
Rachel all right you guys go ahead and
stand to your feet we're going to get
started with Glorious Day tonight
let's sing this out together I
was my
shame who could carry that
kind of
way it was my
[Music]
t i you
I was
breathing but
not
alive all my failures I
tried to
hide it was my
to till I made
you you call my
name and now R out of that
grave out of the
darkness into your glorious
[Music]
day you call my
name and I ran out of that
grave out of the
darkness into your glorious day
[Music]
now your mercy has
saved my soul praise the
Lord and now your
freom is
all that I
know the only may
do Jesus when I made you
you called my
name and I ran out of that
grave out of the
darkness into your glorious
day you call my
name and I R out of that
grave out of the T
Darkness into your glorious
[Music]
day I needed resue my sin was heavy but
chains break at the weight of your glory
I needed shelter I was an orphan now you
call me a citizen of Heaven when I was
broken you are my healing now your love
is the I'm
Brea I have a future my eyes were open
CU When you call my
name I ran out of that
[Music]
CR out of the
darkness into your glorious day
[Music]
you call my
name and I ran out of that
[Music]
grave out of the
darkness into your glorious
[Music]
day all right thank you guys this is my
sister Mel by the way way for those of
you who might not have met her before
she's helping us out tonight on guitar
and I'm so grateful and y'all know Nate
and Don um are up here with me very
thankful for our team and all the
different people who serve up here and
just wanted to say a thank you real
quick to them kiddos y'all are dismissed
you can go on to your classes and your
teachers will meet you over by the doors
thank you kids ministry team I know
Maggie and August are back there tonight
and
Angie thank you thank you
and we are going to go to uh go ahead
and transition into the prayers of the
people um so I think you guys have been
through this with us before you all
follow along and read the parts in R
aloud together and then offer up
whatever you might be carrying into this
space um whenever we have that time of
Silence you can speak those names or
situations
out Jesus for this city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
for suzan and her
sister her
[Music]
brother for Alex and
Lucas Johnny
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence amen
[Music]
the empty fi the wounded healed the
broken back
together the poor are blessed that we
rised we will Dance Forever
[Music]
the blinded see the chained are free the
doubtful now
believer the outcast known the orphan
home you are my
redeemer
behold
behold behold the love can do
behold he making all things
[Music]
new the Lost return the voiceless heard
the M now
rejoicing the mountains shake the world
away creation it all
composing the said and true the Earth
renewed the song has founded
singer the darkness Light the Dead Light
You Are My
Redeemer
behold
behold behold
love do
he's making all things sing that again
behold
behold love can do
behold he's making all things
new we've been struck down but we're not
destroyed we' so
in tears but we'll reap in
joy we been strug down but we're not
destroyed we' s in tears will reap in
Joy my eyes are
Ro yeah my heart eyes are
[Music]
Ro My Eyes Are
Open
oh my eyes are
Ro
behold
behold behold love can do behold
behold he's making all things new
behold
behold behold the love can do
behold he's making all things
[Music]
new he's making all things new
God we do thank you that you are
finishing a
story God that it's not
over but you're up to something in our
lives
in our homes in our
[Music]
communities and we continue to trust you
for that good
work I've carried a
[Music]
bir too long on my
own I
[Music]
to Bear it
alone I hear your
[Music]
invitation to let it all go and I see it
now I'm laying it down and I know that I
need you so I run to the father I fall
into Grace I'm done with the
[Music]
hiding my heart needs
a my soul needs a friend so I run to the
father again and again and again and
[Laughter]
[Music]
again you saw my
condition had a plan from the
start your son for
[Music]
Redemption the price for my
heart I don't have
a for that kind of love I don't know
understand I can't
comprehend all I know
is you I run to the father I fall into
Grace I'm done with the hiding no reason
to wait my heart needs a se My Soul
needs a friend so I run to the father
again and again and and again and
again
[Laughter]
oh
oh again and
again
[Music]
oh my heart has been in your SES long
before my f bre running
into your arms is running to life from
death and I feel this Rush deep in my
chest your mercy is
calling out and just as I am you pull me
in and I know I need you
so I run to the I fall into Grace I'm
with the no reason wait my heart found a
Sur my soul found a friend so I run to
the father again and again I run to the
father I fall into Grace done with the
hiding no reason away
my heart found a sech my soul found a
friend so I run to the father again and
again and again and
again
[Music]
oh
oh again and again oh
[Music]
again and
again
[Music]
again God we
remember that truth in your word that
says though we have been struck down we
are not
destroyed and God whatever we are
carrying whatever we are
facing God we believe that you will see
us
through we believe that you will
continue to guide and direct us that you
will continue to surround us in love and
light you will continue to offer hope
and forgiveness and
[Music]
healing you can transform our situation
you can make all things
new those aren't just words that we want
to sing on a Sunday night God but we
want them to be true in our
lives we want to see you moving and
working and turning things
around and we want to be part of it God
so transform
us make us a people after your heart
heart do your work in our
lives again and again and
[Music]
again we trust you God because you have
shown yourself to be good and
[Music]
trustworthy in Jesus name
amen will you guys welcome the people
sitting around you and say hello before
we move on
well Grace and
peace good to be with you all my name is
Brett and uh yeah a joy joy to be in
this space with you and uh to welcome
you and that includes as always those
join us online love you all lots and uh
anyone here tonight who is new thank you
for being Among Us your presence um yeah
just means a lot to us so um the title
of my message this week is uh simply
well and our passage is James chapter 5
verses 13- 16 and I should I meant to
mention this last week we had another
message on James that this might be
James the brother of Jesus um also might
be just a a different James was a very
popular name back in the day and today I
guess uh so uh you know we don't know
exactly for sure who who wrote this um
but the uh the text reads starting in
verse 13 is anyone among you in trouble
let them pray is anyone happy let them
sing songs of praise is anyone among you
sick let them call the Elders of the
church to pray over them and anoint them
with oil in the name of the Lord and the
prayer offered in faith will make the
sick person well the Lord will raise
them up if they have sinned they will be
forgiven therefore confess your sins to
each other and pray for each other so
that you may be healed the prayer of a
righteous person is powerful and
effective so this is a fascinating
passage the the part that's kind of
always um I should say caught my
attention in particular and at times
sort of bothered me is uh the section
verses 14 and 15 about if someone's sick
let them call the Elders of the church
and the prayer um will make them well
and I remember conversations going all
the way back to like high school my um
my dad was on the Elder like leadership
team of the local church we were part of
and I remember him talking to me about
this passage because as like you know
quote unquote Elder leader of the church
he had been called to people's homes and
the the physical healing at times was
sort of like the the kind of the
exception rather than the rule he had
these kind of moments but it wasn't like
oh I mean it's just it's just that
simple it's like a formula you know what
I mean or just oh you're sick that's
kind of how the text can make it sound
in a way you know I mean like it's just
that easy you just call the you know the
the right person the holy person or
something and they bring their like a
little olive oil or something you know
even better if it's from the land of
Israel and they'll make the sign of the
cross in your head and say a prayer and
that's it you know I mean whether it's
like the sniffles or terminal illness
anything in between just that
easy and uh for that reason it kind of
like it kind of I don't know it didn't
quite sit well with me uh because again
while I have know people had those kinds
of experiences you know uh it do seem to
be a little bit of kind of the the
exception rather than than the rule and
so honestly I kind of felt bad like
honestly a little anxious like oh what
if one of you like calls me you know
what I mean like oh Pastor bre come pray
and then like what if it doesn't work
you know oh God I'm like a little
anxious about your are you going to be
okay you know is this again scripture
that's kind of the question that ends up
kind of bringing up you know is like
well is it like what's the reality here
is I don't know is like does pastor
Brett lack Faith or do I like Faith you
know is or is it like is James wrong
somehow or what you know for all those
reasons I think this kind of a an
interesting uh text and I I think in the
end a lot of it hinges on on that word
well doesn't it and and specifically
kind of the way we're going to translate
that um so the NIV chose the word well
here other translations opt for ReStore
or
heal as in you know the prayer offered
in faith will restore the sick person or
will heal the person who is sick and uh
now here's the thing the Greek word
being translated here as various places
well or healed or restored um is the
Greek word
so uh which means literally it's it's
sort of the root is soo but it means
literally will will be um
saved will be saved that's like the
actual Greek there um which is kind of a
little
interesting twist you know in the in the
text because um now I know why it's
translated into English in that way and
uh I I think it's because well some of
it is our understanding of Salvation
what does it mean to be saved and as if
you've heard me preach before you know
I'm the first one to say being saved it
is more than simply you know kind of my
my soul God Jesus is going to save my
soul and and then I'll go to heaven when
I die that's what it means to be saved
is to believe in Jesus so go to the good
place not the bad place and it's just
like that you know um I do think
salvation it's a a it's a much richer
concept than that um not too different
really than like the word shalom in the
Old Testament which means like to to be
made whole to to be kind of restored
healed
well but can you hear that it's it's
kind of in like a a very holistic and in
ways a deeper sense and in other words I
do think sometimes it means that the
sick person will be made well saved
in in that very like kind of even a
literal like the sickness goes away you
know or whatever um but I think if you
see the kind of deeper undertones there
like could you imagine for example an
instance where
perhaps the sickness doesn't go
away but you're made
well like isn't this um the goodness of
God in our life sometimes that like we
want the situation to change but it's
mostly because we think if the situation
will change then I will be
well does that make sense and and so
what it means to be saved what it means
to be healed what it means to be
restored is to be made well again
sometimes that means the situation
changes the Breakthrough happens the
sickness goes away that you know
sometimes it means that sometimes it
just means you're you're on a path to a
kind of internal like the deeper I would
say even more significant healing you're
becoming
well Body Soul
spirit that like that's the deep
healing in other words even if life is
disappointing you you can be made well
like even if the divorce is still going
through you know you can be made well
even if you're parents or extended
family still just doesn't get
you you can be
well even if you feel
alone you can be
well you can be well like isn't this at
the end of the day I don't know about
you like that's what I'm on a journey
towards that's what I want I want to be
saved in that sense in that deep
profound sense I want to be
well my guess is you want to be
well
too I
uh I came across well for a few years
now I've been uh a fan of the Indie
music artist sufan Stevens anyone a fan
or is this like is I don't know if his
time was kind he was like kind of
getting a little known and I don't know
if he's still you know um old sufan if
you Google it spelled suf Jan it's very
very unique first name so um he came out
this album though the age of odds way
back the good old days
2010 y'all remember yeah 2010 it's funny
I mean isn't amazing how time passes and
like even you know 2004 is like 20 years
ago you know what I mean so back in the
good old days of 200 he came out with
this um this album and uh it's honestly
it's one of his more kind of electronic
at times I mean in keeping with Indie
music it's not just there to make you
feel good you know it's kind of like
introducing conflicting emotions and
such you know through the the music and
I saw some interviews with him where he
kind of admitted that in this album he
was intentionally wanting to kind of
give vent to his kind of his shadow side
he kind of broke onto the scene um as
like sort of that kind of walk on the
line of like is he is he like a a
Christian doing just music you know or
like some people were kind of trying to
peg him as a Christian artist and I
think definitely this album I mean if
the others hadn't kind of broken him out
of that this one for sure did um but
uh and and you kind of see that even in
the opening verses which I'm going to
read in just a moment um you can kind of
hear the the chaos and a little bit of
the the hurt the anger it's it's kind of
a powerful poetry uh and then he kind of
shifts into the chorus and has this
beautiful chor which um I'm G to
actually sing for you so here's what I
want to invite you to do I want you to
close your eyes if you're up for if you
don't have to if you're like I'm going
to have a trauma response okay then
don't just leave your eyes open it's
perfectly fine but if you're comfortable
go and close your eyes and that's why
the lyrics are not going to be on the
screen because I I want to just kind of
read this these lyrics over you Stevens
writes did I go at it
wrong did I go intentionally to destroy
me I'm s suffering in
noise I'm suffering in Touching ordinary
bodies the burning from within the
burning from with ordinary
hysteria I could not be at rest I could
not be at peace extraordinary hysteria
illness likes to pray upon the lonely to
pray upon the lonely when it
bites
oh I'd rather be
dead I would rather give
up but then with longing he
sings I Want To Be Well I want to be
well I want to be well I want to be
well I want to be well I want to be well
I want to to be well I want to be well I
want to be well I want to be well I want
to be well I want to be well I want to
be well I want to be well I want to be
well want to be well I want to be well I
want to be well I want to be well I want
to be well
go ahead and open your
eyes 24 times he sings that in the
chorus I want to be well I want to be
well I want to be well you know as I
look at the
culture I just think that's like a
heart's cry I want to be well I want to
be well I look at the church not just
our church but the broader Community I
think there's a kind of longing I want
to be well
but am I you know am I on the
path and maybe even the deeper question
is sort of a how what would that even
look like to be on that
Journey towards being
well I think James um offers a few ways
in our text verse 13 again is anyone
among you in
trouble let
them freak out
Panic yell blame kick the
dog no is anyone among you in trouble
let them
pray let them pray I think this is um
the first how to be well I can devote
myself to prayer um I think we need a
shift though here um I've mentioned
before I had a big transition in the
idea of Prayer in my own life about um
maybe 10 years ago
growing up as um to kind of paraphrase
the pastor Brian's on um I used to think
prayer was all about getting God to do
what I thought God ought to
do anyone there with me like that was
sort of what prayer is about is
that uh and so the way I kind of
interpreted James here like he made a
lot of sense is anyone among you in
trouble let them pray
right
AKA ask God to change it you know what I
mean like change the person change the
situation like get the get the the thing
better or preferably just out right um
now here's some of the challenge with
that if you've been kind of been on that
path um now just to be clear I should
mention as a caveat I'm not in any way
against sort of petition this is what's
called petitionary prayer pray right
asking God to for a breakthrough for a
healing for you know a situation to
change or something you know that's okay
to I mean Jesus talks about that in the
Lord's Prayer um you know give us this
day our daily bread and forgive and you
know there's there's something beautiful
about that so it's it's
um I would say it's just not um the main
thing
and so that the transition because well
I should say the challenge with it is
there's always another
situation so in other words it's like
Lord change this and then like that
changes and it's like okay now this okay
now this okay now this and then I need
this and then also this in other words
it's sort of a NeverEnding process of
like it's just thing after thing after
thing after thing um I recently uh I
went through a whole ordeal
with my car had to buy a new car over
July break because um well my other one
just fell to Pieces uh literally it's
like um I well just everything went out
at once you ever had that moment with a
car just like everything's fly so had to
get a new one and long story short
through no fault of my
own um without sounding too defensive
you say we had a few issues with the
title it was a used car and it had a few
issues with the title and so I found
myself at the
DMV not
once multiple times and that I don't
like for me that is my idea of
hell I was in bureaucratic hell
Kafkaesque it was just the freaking
worst and it's just you know it's like
details and things I don't know about
and like ask me questions was like I
just oh my my anxiety youall know I
struggle with anxiet so it was just
through the RO like it was just oh my
gosh like I could not take it and it was
like honestly for like a week it just
consumed me honestly I had no other
problems except this problem this giant
problem I mean I woke up in the morning
first thing I thought about you know it
was one of those situ just oh just
eating and so I prayed to God I was like
Lord this is the last thing you know
there's I just need one more thing I
just I promise I will never be anxious
again if only we could like knock down
this problem get me through
Lord and within like few weeks took a
little while but
breakthrough things got better I had a
Rosy Glow for 24 hours I was Problem
free like it was
incredible and then
something else arose it was like the
next thing came up the next problem the
next thing to be anxious about the and I
realize like oh my gosh like it's it's
it's happening um I think this is why we
need to drastically begin to re
understand prayer here I'll quote Pastor
Brian Zant who wrote the primary purpose
of prayer is not to get God to do what
we think God ought to do the primary
purpose of prayer is to be properly
formed
that's that's the
shift that prayer uh again it's primary
right right so it's not only exclusively
it's not that it's just primary as
opposed to
secondary
and in in essence it's prayer where it's
not so much God change that situation
change that person if you just fixed
them all my problems you know you know
the first uh but now what is it it's
about
formation it's God created in me a new
heart do a new thing in me there's a
it's an in you might think of it as um
prayer as Divine
therapy this is how I'm beginning to
understand prayer it's divine therapy
it's it's a it's a inner healing kind of
process and I I want to give you a few
kind of tangible ways this kind of kind
of looks um and so let me give you yeah
let me just give you a few examples um
it can look like chanting reading or
singing the
Psalms this is like goes way back in
church history kind of lost though in a
lot of kind of modern kind of protestant
forms of church because again it's like
why would I like pray the Psalms when
I've got situations I need God to fix
you know what I mean it's like I just a
waste of time I need to bring up the
important things but when you realize
it's prayer as formation that it's those
The Poetry the Psalms kind it begins to
get into you it gives voice impact next
week we'll be uh doing a message on
lament and like half the Psalms are
lament so it's this kind of poetry
that's kind of arising from within us
and it gives us language for what we're
feeling uh now I mentioned chanting here
which might I don't know if that freaks
people out um there's something so
chanting again was kind of sort of a a
very common way to sing the Psalms and
uh even it's kind of being rediscovered
I think a little bit in Christian
circles partly because it's very calming
so if you think of like singing right
has sort of different melody lines and
you're changing notes constantly a chant
tends to be kind of monotone until the
end you know might have like a little up
and down thing at the end but it's just
sort of a
monotone you know it's just a kind of
flat thing but if you think even of
something as practical as breathing what
is that doing to your breathing what's
that
quick you chant the whole
line it's like incorporating kind of
breathing and practic into P to the the
Psalms uh in fact I heard this story a
musicologist had talked about this where
there was a a Benedictine Christian
abster in France somewhere and for years
like they chant like a lot they chant
through all the Psalms every week and
this was chanting the I mean the prayers
and everything it was like a huge part
of their Rhythm and they would um they
went through a change though in their
liturgy and they reduced their chanting
like
tremendously and what happened is
suddenly the monks were
exhausted like all the time because they
already didn't get a ton of sleep maybe
sixish hours and they realized after
like a few months of this they're like
oh my gosh we have to bring back the
chanting because that was doing
something to it spiritually was it their
nervous system was it just physically I
don't something was calming and healing
and restoring them in the in other words
the the way they prayed was also forming
them so that's just one example you
could if you want like more info on this
you can like do a YouTube search or
something find out how to chant or sing
or pray the Psalms um another form is
praying The Lord's Prayer this is found
in Matthew chapter 6 um or Luke 11 is
like the shorter version um you can pray
the Jesus prayer this is like a short
repetitive prayer that's um the longer
version is Lord Jesus Christ Son of God
have mercy on me a sinner some people
have shortened that to just Lord Jesus
Christ Son of God have mercy or even
just Lord Jesus Christ Son of God and
you just pray that like a thousand times
you know like it's literally it's just
that kind of repetitive prayer which
again when you're thinking of prayer and
purely petitionary ways it's like why
would I ever do that why would I what's
the point you know but when you realize
it's prayer as formation they said um
folks who have practiced that form of
prayer say eventually it's almost as
though the prayer is praying you the
prayer gets so kind of sunk down into
your being into Deep Mind into your
subconscious that it's like it just
keeps going it can be very grounding um
you can use prayer books to guide your
prayers uh
you can engage centering prayer other
forms of Christian meditation this would
be kind of like a very shortened version
of the Jesus prayer where instead of a
phrase it's just like a word you know
love
abide I this that last one um is this is
one of my favorite forms of prayer that
I've discovered in the last 10 years is
centering prayer and uh one of my most
uh kind of powerful moments with it was
you know the whole idea is you kind of
sit there in silence and then when you
find your mind drifting you repeat that
word as a sign of your intention to
return to the Lord's presence and so i'
done this you know like years it was a
long time and one day I'm in my My
Little Words abide and so I'm in this
moment and I'm about to freak out on one
of my kids and I'm about to lose it and
suddenly what emerges from the depths of
my mind that one word I had repeated 20
,000 times you know what I mean it just
kind of
like and I was
like you know like
stop now I can't claim I've since then
I've never been upset again you know
okay let's not go too far with this but
it it has been a powerful kind of
practice again this is prayer as um
formation um second I can devote myself
to
authenticity
authenticity I think often confession of
sins and such has been sort of framed in
like a very you know negative light and
at times has you can be kind of
weaponized and used to like manipulate
people and such um so I want to kind of
try to ReDiscover this so the way he
James puts it verse 16 therefore confess
your sins to each other and pray for
each other so that you may be healed um
there is something so
beautiful uh
about living life with a certain
authenticity and a a certain
fearlessness not that you need to open
up to every person or something but when
you're in the presence of someone you
know or trust that there's no kind of
wall you know that wall we have between
us and the world uh in fact I was just
with I just had lunch with someone right
before I came here and I was shocked to
death because we're just talking over
lunch and I could tell they had no wall
and suddenly they start sharing things
with me about their life that was like
incred edibly
vulnerable and I
immediately felt so
connected relationally to them you know
we often feel like in our life we feel
like I just don't have connection with
people you know maybe it's a marriage
where it's just like there's just no
intimacy anymore I don't just mean
sexual I just mean any sort of relation
just where do the Good Vibes go where
did the connection where what
happened um often this is what's lacking
a kind of sharing of the heart right not
just what I think but what I
feel and or maybe it's a church you know
I just don't feel really connected and I
just don't I don't know I just feel
distant from everyone you know what's
going on there how many people or is
there anyone you're kind of you know
opening up to you know maybe you even
like obviously a place we do this a lot
is meetups or small groups where but you
could go to a Meetup and still feel kind
of on the inside a thousand miles from
people they can have you can go there
for 5
years right because what's what's
missing kind of
authenticity transparency ay hey here's
what's really going on and here's how I
feel about it you know and I think again
kind of taking James as a jumping off
point I think it's more than just sins
you know oh confess your sins or what's
what you messed up on this goes beyond
that I hope you can tell it's it's
feeling its experiences its
fears um and shortcomings and struggle
it's it's all that a kind of beginning
to operate with that that sort of
openness in short I would say the
greater my vulnerability with others the
deeper my sense of
healing so in closing I uh I think we
all want to be well so my prayer is that
as we devote ourselves to these
practices may God find us may God lead
us towards the healing that we so
desperately need in the name of the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
amen so on the night Jesus was betrayed
he had one final meal with his disciples
and at that meal he held up a loaf of
bread and he broke it and he said this
is my body broken for you then he held
up a cup of wine and he said this is my
blood shed for you whenever you eat this
bread whenever you drink this cup
remember
me and so tonight as we come to the
table uh that's what we're participating
in that's the the story and the the god
that we're being invited to um to
connect with so um the way that we'll go
about participating communion tonight is
we'll start with uh just the kind of
front rows here and um they'll kind of
form a line and we'll just all kind of
gather go row by row um we practice
what's called an Open Table meaning if
you're here tonight and you want to
participate then you feel free to do
that you should know the red is wine and
the white is grape juice so this is the
table not of the church but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come you who have much faith and
you who have little you who have been
here often and you who have not been
here long you who have tried to follow
and you who failed come because it's the
Lord Jesus himself who invites you and
it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here come to
the table
[Music]
for
in
[Music]
for
tonight we're going to close with a hymn
that I'm sure you either know or have
heard at some point in your life um
Called It is Well if you guys would
stand and sing these lyrics with us in
that Spirit of wellness and Desiring
God's Wellness in our lives Liv maybe
even despite some of the prayers that
we're still praying some of the
questions that we still have um but
really seeking after um being settled in
our spirit with The Wellness of God
when
peace like a
[Music]
r
a my
way when
Sorrows like
sea
Billows
roll
whatever my my
Lord thou has
t me to
say it is
well it Is
Well with My
Soul my
sin oh the
Bliss of this
glorious
thought my
sin not in
part but in
[Music]
hope his
name to the
cross and I
be know
praise the
Lord praise the
Lord my
soul it is
[Music]
with with My
Soul with My
Soul it is is
well it Is
Well with My
[Music]
Soul Sing It is Well it Is
Well with My
Soul with
my it is well
It Is
Well with My
Soul and
Lord Hast the
day when my face shall be
S the
CL be rolled
back and us
gr
the shall
ReSound and the
Lord shall
be even
so it Is
Well with My Soul
it is
way it is
way with my
soul my
soul It is
Well it Is
Well with My Soul
It is
Well it Is
Well with My
[Music]
Soul thank you all for being here
tonight thank you guys for that um
it is so powerful um to get to
experience sing that song in a room of
Believers that you feel
like have the same heart and you're
going towards the same place I haven't
been able to sing and worship for a long
time um and so being with people who are
affirming and want to be inclusive um
that's just really powerful so thank you
guys for that um if you're a visitor uh
well anybody thank you so much for
joining us this evening if you are new
we'd love for you to fill out the QR
code um that's going to be on the screen
just so we can answer any questions you
might have about what this community
looks like and just say thank you for
being here um if you're in need of
prayer or a hug or just general support
again my name is Rachel you can come
find me after the service I'll be right
over there I would love to be there for
you however I
can um generosity is a key aspect of a
life of adoration and worship if you
would like to give financially to the
work that done here at the table you can
scan that QR code or you can go to the
TBL tx.org
okay now I'm going to send you um into
your week with a blessing you can hold
out your hands in a posture to receive
or just open your heart to these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and
and it's true on your worst day so as
you go into your week ahead with its yet
to be determined highs and lows and
everything in between go filled with the
assurance that you are loved you are
worthy and you are accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come into contact with be
blessed we'll see you next Sunday and
don't forget about state of the table
right after this thank
you it is